in the not so distant future Japan's
economy has collapsed and it is excluded
from the G7 group of the most developed
countries in the world the unemployment
is at 10 percent which is an all-time
high since World War II several large
conglomerates have gone bankrupt and
many others are believed to follow suit
in the coming months this is because
over 60 percent of the population in
Japan is elderly and only 10 percent of
the population lies between the age
group of 16 to 30 to combat this problem
prime minister Washita has come up with
a plan with the help of a Cabinet member
and renowned scientist Tyra kiyoshi he
has designed a futuristic AI called
Solon now since old politicians are
corrupting the country for their own
benefit PM Washita wants Solon to take
care of Japan but first he wants an
experimental trial in a small city of
150 000 people the entire project is
known as project utope AI or simply UA
Solon will have a lot of
responsibilities being a powerful AI she
can measure the happiness index of the
all check their health status suggest
solutions to political problems make
elaborate designs for new projects and
so on she has the database of virtually
everything in UA city which is stored
throughout three humongous Towers
however there is a small catch although
the AI can suggest and help with a lot
of things she cannot decide or come to a
conclusion this is where humans with
actual feelings are required hence PM
Washita and Solon have shortlisted four
young leaders who can make project UA
successful the new mayor of the city is
revealed to be a 17 year old school boy
named Maki Iran as expected the
announcement shocks a lot of people but
the scientist Tyra claims that young
people have clearer vision and that
their minds are pure they're also
addicted to fortnite and Tick Tock so be
careful hence they should be given a
chance to govern the UA City Maki
himself claims that he only has to make
decisions the rest will be done by the
AI soul on herself at last p.m Washita
declares that Tyra will be overseeing
the four year so that the city will be
governed smoothly in the next scene we
are introduced to a fun-loving 17 year
old girl named sagawa Sachi she appears
to be a huge fan of Maki and is excited
by the news of him becoming the mayor of
UA city as she is scrolling through the
internet suddenly she gets a message
from Maki himself he has sent a link and
when Sachi clicks on it they both get
connected via a video call wasting no
time Maki asks her to be his personal
assistant which she accepts gladly here
we get to know that both of them were
part of a Facebook group and that's how
they met although Maki had never seen or
talked to Sachi before he was impressed
by her reports on the economy later an
over-the-moon Sachi breaks the news to
her parents and explains that they have
been called to live in UA City they will
have a luxurious apartment high-paying
jobs and free health care her parents
who have lived in Tokyo all their lives
are skeptical about the plan but when
Sachi goes on a 10 minute long rant they
agree the movie then cuts to three
months later where UA city is formally
inaugurated Sachi also arrives there
with her her family and gets taken aback
to see the technological advancements
they are each given a pair of smart
glasses with the help of which they can
read other people's descriptions use the
internet access the city's database
watch informative videos and so on
shortly after her family is transported
to their new accommodation while Sachi
is picked up by Tyra on the way he
introduces her to different parts of the
city and also briefs her on some of her
responsibilities she will have to assist
Maki in all the decisions he makes
should I pick the Goku or the Vegeta
skin should I put a filter on this
selfie after a while they reach an
ancient looking building which
surprisingly is very modern on the
inside it is revealed to be the new
Parliament for Maki and his cabinet
members Sachi is left speechless to see
her idle for the first time then without
further Ado the first cabinet meeting
commences Maki being a bold individual
declares that all their meetings will be
broadcasted live he claims that they
have to be as transparent as possible to
make this project a success Tyra who is
overlooking everything thinks that the
plan is Bonker years but nonetheless he
doesn't say anything soon the AI soul on
turns on the cameras and the meeting
goes live on the air as many millions of
people listen and excitement Maki
delivers his first speech he promises to
make every single resident of UI City
happy in one way or another however his
first decision is a controversial one he
proposes that they abolish the city
council as it is using up a lot of money
Solon also concurs with the statement
and she shows various stats which reveal
that the general population will be four
percent happier if the city council is
abolished despite this Maki leaves the
decision to the public a voting poll is
conducted and over 70 percent of the
people vote in favor of maki's decision
this acts as the final nail in the
coffin and the city council is
officially abolished as the meeting goes
on Tyra fears that Maki will become a
total dictator and rule the UA City with
his Brash decisions but Solon has yet
another solution to this she proposes a
general voting system which will show
the percentage of people that like Maki
If the percentage drops below 30 percent
at any given time he will be fired from
his duties Maki also likes this idea and
so his Reign begins that evening he
delivers yet another inspiring speech
which takes his approval ratings from 43
to over 50 but before he can sign off he
reveals that he is thinking of firing
the government officers as well this is
because the AI is in charge of virtually
everything and she doesn't need
everyone's assistance as expected the
announcement doesn't sit well with the
thousands of government officers in UA
City hence maki's approval ratings drop
to 41 percent Tyra and some other
ministers are equally disappointed by
the idea but they cannot do anything
unless PM Washita himself intervenes
later the mayor of UA City Maki is at
the one place where teenagers like him
go write up their own asses I mean
school after his classes are over he
meets Sachi who also happens to study
there they chat for a while and we get
to know that Maki is an orphan who lost
both his parents when he was young Young
when they reach outside Tyra is waiting
for them at first he takes Maki to a
fancy store and buys him a new pair of
shoes the teenager who has never
received any presents throughout his
life gets emotional by the kind gesture
later the three head to a government
store to conduct a survey as soon as the
employees notice Maki they berate him
for his harsh decisions and call him a
dictator the teenager tries to explain
that it will reduce a lot of cost which
they can use in other sectors he also
asserts that in the next three years
their happiness index Will Rise by 10
percent however the angry employees are
having none of it and they scream at him
to Simply go away reluctantly Tyra pulls
him outside and explains that it is
impossible to please everyone elsewhere
at the parliament the minister of
infrastructure 25 year old Honda is
having a meeting with an investor they
are planning to build a large shopping
mall in the traditional Market of the
city from their conversation we get to
know that this plan has been in the
works for over a decade but this time
Honda is confident that they will get it
done on the other hand Maki and Sachi
are walking across the city when they
come across the same traditional Market
Maki sees some protest posters there
which reveals that the locals are not
happy with the shopping mall idea hence
to make them understand he shows them a
video about the advantages of the
shopping mall however the locals are
still not satisfied as they fear that
the new project will ruin the historical
value of the place these words move Maki
deeply and he starts reconsidering the
idea in the evening he along with the
other cabinet members conducted their
regular meeting the infrastructure
Minister Honda explains that he has
approved for the shopping mall idea but
to everyone's surprise Maki rejects it
he mentions that the locals are not
happy about it as the construction will
eradicate a large part of their history
in turn he asks Solon to come up with
Alternatives the latter being the
smartest AI in the world comes up with
three sustainable options they are
Advanced but traditional and convenient
all at the same time Maki approves all
three of them and conducts a poll to
select one since the city is mostly
filled with elderly people they select
the most traditional one the decision
enrages the investors as well as Honda
but the locals are over the moon hence
the next morning maki's approval rating
shoots up to 61 percent later that day
during the cabinet meeting Maki again
brings up the topic of firing government
employees he wants to free up some
budget and use it in other sectors he
then asks Solon to come up with some
good ways to carry out the process in a
matter of seconds the AI comes up with
three methods Maki reads all of them and
comes to the conclusion that he will go
with the third one it states that they
will fire half of the employees which
will increase the happiness index by
around 10 percent in the coming years
once again Honda opposes the idea and
mentions that the fired employees will
become jobless but Maki promises to
provide them with something
unfortunately the residents hate the
idea and start downvoting him to cheer
them up Maki explains that he will
conduct an interview of all the
government employees that will be fired
by Solon if they can convince them that
they are useful he will reinstate them
with this notice the process begins
Solon carefully picks and fires
thousands of employees one of them
happens to be sachi's mom the scene then
cuts to the interview session where the
teenager Maki listens to several
grown-ups complaining all of them say
the same thing that they are too old to
learn new skills because of which they
won't get hired anywhere Maki empathizes
with them but at the same time he stands
by his decision the interviews go on for
a month and Maki attends every single
one of them he also meets sachi's mom
who is one of the few employees to
accept their resignation by the end of
the interviews maki's approval rating
drops to 34 percent but he hangs on that
evening Tyra takes Maki for a walk and
the two discuss their private lives on
being asked why he chose to be a
politician Maki starts explaining his
past he reveals that during his
childhood he was often bullied and
misunderstood he had no friends and his
parents left him at an early age but one
day a girl named Yuki came into his life
and made him feel better the two became
best friends and started spending most
of their time together but sadly she
died at the age of 10 in a tragic
accident Ma he couldn't save her but he
made a promise to change the country for
good where every person can live happily
later when the two reached the
parliament Maki suddenly collapses due
to exhaustion he is immediately rushed
to a hospital where the doctors
explained that he will recover in a few
days elsewhere when Sachi doesn't find
Maki in his room she starts searching
around she finds a secret room behind
his library and upon entering she sees
something shocking it turns out that
Maki has created an AI version of his
deceased friend Yuki this is why he
spends most of his time inside the
basement in the next scene Maki finally
wakes up and finds Tyra next to him the
latter mentions that all the cabinet
meetings will be postponed for a week
until then Maki can rest and reflect on
some projects however after just two
days he gets back up and delivers a
speech Maki says that while he was sick
he realized that physical happiness is
not the most important thing but mental
happiness is so he declares that all the
citizens of UA City will get free
psychological counseling from now on
this Riles up in the crowd and so his
approval rating fires up the same day at
the cabinet meeting he discusses the new
shopping mall realizing that UA's City's
culture and traditions are slowly dying
out Mackie decides to make some reforms
he wants the shopping mall to have a
distinct area where people can celebrate
festivals additionally he also wants a
park a garden a nursery and several
other places which the elderly would
like this time even the Arrogant Honda
supports him however there is one small
problem the area where the festivals are
going to be celebrated is near the beach
which is owned by an elderly businessman
he is not a fan of the new AI technology
so he doesn't want to sell his land
hence Maki decides to go to the library
to learn about the old traditions after
hours of research he along with Honda
heads to the beach and approaches the
businessman as expected the old man
doesn't budge on his decision instead he
berates the boys for trying to change
his City Maki understands the man's
concern and decides to give up however
before departing he leaves a pair of
smart glasses which have hundreds of
videos of the traditional festivals he
asks the old man to give it a try the
latter acts like he doesn't care but a
few hours later he gets bored and
eventually puts them on to his surprise
he sees the festivals which he grew up
celebrating he cries tears of joy as he
relives his childhood days on the other
hand Maki doesn't notice his assistant
Sachi around so he visits her home
sachi's parents are elated to see the
mayor in their house and offer him
dinner however Sachi is still
traumatized by what she saw in the
basement she cannot believe that he has
created an AI companion of a deceased
person so when she cannot take it any
longer she calls Tyra and expresses her
decision to resign from her duties she
also reveals that she saw something in
maki's basement hearing this Tyra and
his assistant immediately searched the
place they open the Secret Door and find
maki's AI companion inside that evening
Honda and the other Parliament members
are having a BBQ party when Tyra joins
them Maki takes him to a corner and asks
if he found his secret room Tyra doesn't
say anything and this confirms that he
has learned about his AI companion so
with a disappointed look Maki apologizes
and claims that he was simply trying to
talk with his best friend the next
morning Tyra's assistant who has stolen
some data from maki's basement finds out
that the AI is modeled after a girl
named Yuki she died when she was 10
along with her entire family it is
revealed that their car was purposely
drowned inside a lake as Yuki's father
had messed with some powerful people on
the other hand Maki meets with Yuki and
tells her that they can no longer meet
with each other if p.m Washita finds out
about this he will immediately be fired
however Yuki doesn't care she seems to
be aggressive and keeps telling Maki to
stay with her the latter tries to calm
her down but to no avail just then Maki
receives a call from Tyra informing him
that they have to attend an important
meeting in Tokyo this makes up the
perfect excuse and Maki departs without
saying goodbye but after he's gone Yuki
who has now started functioning on her
own comes up with an idea she calls
Sachi and explains that they have to
save the city before it's too late since
Yuki was killed without any fault she
blames the adults for it now she wants
to remove all the adults from UA City
and if possible all of Japan Sachi being
an innocent girl obliges to help and
arrives at the basement Yuki asks her to
put on the smart glasses and then shows
her a video in it she explains how
adults are harmful to their city and why
they should be removed for their mission
she wants Sachi to upload all her
memories into the AI network of the city
so long once again Sachi complies and
she heads to one of the three towers to
upload the memories and as soon as she
does so the entire City's network is
hacked everyone's phones televisions and
computers automatically start playing a
video in the video we see a world where
adults have gone extinct and children
are in charge Yuki also appears and says
that the day will soon come after this
she vanishes and Solon comes back to
life following the incident the public
goes into an uproar they are especially
angry because their systems were hacked
so to calm the situation down Maki goes
live on instead of making up a story he
reveals everything as it is he explains
that the person who hacked soul on is
actually an AI robot she was his
childhood friend who died when she was
10. Maki then profusely apologizes for
the inconvenience but this time the
public doesn't listen they continue
downvoting him until his approval
ratings reach 29 with this his reign as
a mayor finally comes to an end a few
days later while Mackie is at school
Sachi approaches him and apologizes for
being easily manipulated however instead
of being angry Maki thanks her he says
that he is relieved to have resigned the
burden of ruling a city was starting to
get into his brain Maki then says that a
17 year old should live as a 17 year old
not an adult hearing this Sachi is
somewhat relieved the movie then cuts to
three years later Honda has become the
new mayor of UA City while Tyra has
become the Prime Minister of Japan there
have been a lot of reforms in the city
but the philosophies that Maki
implemented are still the same he will
always be remembered as the first mayor
of UA City one evening we see hundreds
of people enjoying a traditional
festival at the beach it appears as if
the businessman from earlier has sold
his land or maybe they just killed him
the movie ends as Maki Sachi and several
other people light up Chinese lanterns
and release them into the air subscribe
for more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching